apparently you met someone who has since
reached out to us this is uh Jay Elmore
and he's the executive chef of EJ's
luncheonette in New York City and he
says that he would like to name some
specials after the hosts of the podcast
a Gorly Burger I'm obsessian salad a
Conan sandwich any ingredient I'll make
it happen someone was silly enough to
put me in charge of a restaurant and I'm
desperate for new ideas for specials
that's it this is nice I love this I
think I remembered meeting this
gentleman right outside EJ's
luncheonette and um I would love I'll
say
it's a slippery slope this sandwich
thing because I remember getting a
sandwich named after me once at a deli
in New York City and I was thrilled
thrilled and it was the Conan and you
know corned beef and you know uh Russian
dressing and all this great stuff and I
was so thrilled it was at a Midtown
Diner and what happens is you're excited
and you go in and you look up and you
see your name up there and it's up there
with you know get the Liza Minnelli hot
dog yeah you know
um get the Ed Sheeran chilled broth uh
and then
um there's the Conan and I was so
excited and proud and then I think I
wandered by like a year later gone oh no
and so here's the here's the thing about
Show Business you're so excited when you
start on the way up
and then
the inevitable fall come on no the
sandwich disappeared the sandwich
disappears this is not a default of the
sandwich not you no I'm just saying that
I'm excited to for us to create these
sandwiches they're going to be at EJ's
yeah right luncheonette and I'm very
excited about this and we should each
think right now about what we want
but also I'm just telling you kids as
the old veteran that one day you're
going to go by EJ's and you're going to
see oh you know there's the uh there's
the son of obsessian uh hummus wrap or
whatever why oh
it's not like with lamb and why because
you love your native plants my native
love Glam or land either one's fine but
anyway come on no it's true and you know
the Gorly mayonnaise sandwich it's just
mayonnaise it's just mayonnaise that
sounds pretty good but anyway I'm
telling you there's gonna be the thrill
but then you're gonna wander by and then
inevitably it's gone no and then you
feel the crushing blow that's you
because you had a sandwich named after
you that's exciting it's not gonna be
there forever but you're like oh is it
still there it's not well I must be
irrelevant then I should just go die
that's what I that's what I said that's
not normal that's what I exactly said
when I saw that they had taken my
sandwich away from this Midtown
establishment yeah but it does it it was
there once who cares if it's not there
anymore it's an honor just to be Nom Nom
nominated don't be sad it's not there be
happy it ever happened I don't know what
the saying what did you just I'm
nominated
I'm sorry he's been yeah I can tell when
you've been crafting an arrow
where Sona and I are jabbering away and
you're in the background crafting it
that one I didn't sit on for about time
and then you're all ready oh trust me no
the horribleness of it came through no I
think it needed to be run over this show
is sponsored by better help so I know
you're uh very busy yeah you've got
twins yes twins who are over two now
they're gonna be two in July it's very
easy to find yourself uh doing things
for other people or uh trying to be
really productive and get a lot done and
take care of everybody I know you're a
caretaking personality yeah I am so are
you and and what happens sometimes is
you'd realize I haven't checked in on
myself I have no clue how I'm doing yeah
I bring this up because I'm a big
believer in talk therapy if you if you
can find the right fit right person and
getting help it's made a huge difference
in my life yeah in some ways I've been
your therapist over the years you have
been you've been and I and I think that
you're
so I figured if I could just talk to you
I'll just do it for free but it is so it
is important to talk to someone if
you're thinking of starting therapy
maybe give better help a try here's what
I like about betterhelp it's entirely
online this didn't exist back in the day
when I was
maybe looking for someone to talk to and
it's such a smart way to get involved in
this process better help is designed to
be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule find more balance with
better help I really think this is a
terrific idea visit betterhelp.com Conan
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash Conan let's talk about
the positive what are your sandwiches
going to be what do you want mine's a
hummus wrap no no seriously what is it I
don't know what do you want it to be
yeah what's your like what when you
first said that I was like well
obviously a Euro
I know because I see you eating that
food all the time it's not because I
love it I'm not profiling you I'm saying
that that's what you really like when
you say it you are being like well
sona's ethnic so let's put some hummus
in there I say it because I actually do
love Euros they're my favorite things
I've been watching you eat them for 15
years I've been watching you eat them
for 15 years and then I'm the one that's
bad because I'm pointing out what you
already like
yes thank you oh I have to wait till you
say the sandwich you eat every day yes
and then you said lamb so what do you
want what do you want to call it the
Sona is going to be what specifically oh
specifically I'm not that can you guys
come back to me girls you just said it
was it's on a Euro yeah so don't cut the
them Obsession Euro because it's that's
hard to pronounce so just call it the
Sona Europe it's the Sona Euro do you
want any special ingredients in there
besides what's normally in a year I
don't want any ing tomatoes
in there okay yeah I don't want it maybe
it says underneath the Sona Euro no
Tomatoes I think that's the key
we got and what about you Gorly I think
I'm gonna be in uh because he said
Burger but I really love a patty melt
but we'll call it the Matty pelt
okay that sandwich will I mean it just
sounds that will disappear immediately
helped Pelt come close to mind uh a
scalps I'm gonna put scallops in a pelt
I want the beef to have grown a week's
amount of of mold that just looks like a
pelt okay why not just the Matty melt
it's this yeah just call it Matty melt
yeah get the Maddie melt okay so what's
what and so what is it
what is on it well it's it's uh soured
no let's go rock no sourdough bread with
a beef a thin beef patty yep like a
Smash burger patty cool
um
American cheese
and then there's
um a thousand maybe a little Thousand
Island
right oh
these are the most boring ingredients
and you're saying them you're saying
them as if you've come up with the
magical way to turn lead into gold
behold
thin Patty and then no one saw this
coming some cheese and just a tiny bit
of grilled onions grilled onions oh and
here's something I'm gonna put in there
Thousand Island I'm gonna and also it
should have a little toothpick with an
American flag that doesn't include
Hawaii in honor of it being like it's
the 50s yeah yeah pre-alaska and pre
Hawaii 48 48 states flag little
I just thought what if EJ's assistant
they're gonna get some very confused
customers okay I know what I want and
it's very simple and it's not a bit I
love uh a corned beef sandwich
um with uh coleslaw Russian dressing
same one that got I know
it looks same a sandwich that uh that I
tried before I think that one also had
some turkey this time I'm just going
hardcore it's corned beef it's all
corned beef Russian dressing I love
Russian dressing yeah me too oh I want
to change something I don't want
sourdough bread I want Hawaiian bread
for mine because that's what makes it
different and that's what makes it
delicious EJ's can't stock Hawaiian
bread I love the one in a 100
000 times someone wants your sandwich
and it's gonna have the flag with no Hoy
on the flag okay all right oh I see so I
love Hawaiian bread it's so good I don't
know what Hawaiian bread
yeah it's all stuck together it comes in
that pack and it's laying flat it all
stuck together and you pull them apart
and they're like little little rolls
yeah okay well EJ's uh good luck with
your with your final year in business as
a restaurant
if you want to enjoy any of these tasty
treats go quickly
before this guy wises up
and learns at a time only yes you've
probably only got hours to get to EJ's
luncheonette and try and buy these
sandwiches but sir it was nice meeting
you
um on the street yeah and please never
try and you many businesses have tried
to ride the Conan O'Brien train to Big
riches and it never works out